[Musique]
LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec MGEN mutuelle santé prévoyance
présente état de santé
[Musique]
la recherche en santé publique est
essentielle pour mieux comprendre ce qui
influence la santé elle étudie non pas
les individus mais la population dans
son ensemble
on a besoin de
dizaines de milliers centaines de
milliers de personnes et de beaucoup de
données collectées dans le temps
recherche en santé publique et donc un
outil puissant sur lequel basé des
politiques de prévention la santé elle
se construit là où on est où on grandit
où l'on vit où l'on travaille et surtout
elle se construit dès le plus jeune âge
alors comment faire de cette recherche
un moteur de l'action politique à quoi
sert la santé publique c'est le thème de
ce numéro d'état de santé
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cet état
de santé on a tous une idée de ce que
c'est que la recherche fondamentale la
recherche avec les pipettes les ordis
les calculs qui trouvent des médicaments
par exemple qui soignent directement on
sait un peu moins ce que c'est que la
recherche en santé publique or elle est
partout la recherche en santé publique
c'est par exemple elle qui a permis de
nous faire savoir que le tabac
provoquait le cancer du poumon c'est
considérable bonjour à vous docteur
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous vous
êtes médecin en santé publique docteur
Karim oudkassy on va voir votre parcours
dans un instant mais forcément envie de
vous demander pourquoi êtes-vous docteur
en santé publique vous ne voyez pas de
malade vous n'êtes plus clinicien donc
vous soignez quoi et bien écoutez je
soigne des populations voilà et
effectivement j'ai toujours été
passionné par le fait politique en santé
par la question des inégalités de santé
depuis mon plus jeune âge et donc c'est
tout naturellement que je me suis
orienté dans des études de médecine et
dans une spécialisation en santé
publique alors vous êtes un oiseau rat
ou est-ce que c'est très recherché alors
il y a effectivement très peu de
médecins spécialistes en santé publique
je pense que votre question n'est pas
anodine c'est vrai que c'est pas naturel
de s'orienter vers la santé publique
quand on se lance dans des études de
médecine mais voilà je fais partie de
ces personnes là comme je le disais qui
peuvent être ou intéressés par le fait
politique ou par les statistiques
l'épidémiologie vous allez nous dire à
quel point c'est important la recherche
en santé publique d'abord on regarde
votre portrait
[Musique]
médecin de santé publique Karim ou de
cassis et spécialisé en organisation et
gestion des systèmes de santé il a
notamment travaillé sur le suivi des
patients atteints du VIH ou encore sur
l'organisation de l'offre hospitalière
au sein de la RS Picardie
il est aujourd'hui directeur de la
Fondation MGEN pour la santé publique
qui vise à apporter une meilleure
connaissance de la santé des populations
et collabore régulièrement avec des
organismes de recherche publique tels
que l'Inserm
[Musique]
docteur question définition quand même
parce que santé publique c'est un peu
vague qu'est-ce que c'est que la
recherche en santé publique alors il
existe plein de définitions je vous
rassure je vais pas vous les citer mais
une des choses qui caractérise la santé
publique c'est je l'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure on traite des populations cette
approche populationnelle donc ça c'est
vraiment une première chose qui
caractérise la santé publique la
deuxième chose qui est importante c'est
que en fait c'est plusieurs disciplines
la santé publique en réalité c'est
l'épidémiologie c'est les statistiques
c'est l'informatique mais c'est aussi
l'économie quand on travaille sur les
épidémies diocés si on en a parlé
récemment les pays on fait de la santé
publique on essaye de comprendre on
compare on voit si le virus qui amène
une épidémie et comparable un autre qui
est allé sur un autre continent c'est ça
c'est très concret
c'est un exemple concret donc la santé
publique ça permet d'observer
d'observer les maladies d'observer les
facteurs de risque des maladies ça
permet aussi de surveiller surveiller
les populations voir s'il y a des
épidémies certes qui surviennent mais
pas uniquement on parle aussi des
risques environnementaux par exemple un
autre exemple concret de ce que peut
être la santé publique c'est le
traitement que vous prenez est-ce qu'il
est sûr est-ce qu'il marche bah ça c'est
la santé publique qui permet de répondre
à cette question c'est considérable
infographie regardez là pour achever ces
questions qu'est-ce que la santé
publique
[Musique]
est-ce que le tabac provoque le cancer
du poumon faut-il se méfier des pilules
de troisième génération comment mieux
prendre en charge la perte d'autonomie
ou encore la chirurgie ambulatoire
donne-t-elle de meilleurs résultats
autant de questions qui ont un point
commun la recherche en santé publique
que se cache-t-il derrière ce terme très
vaste pour résumer c'est comprendre
l'influence des facteurs qui déterminent
la santé des populations et proposer des
actions et des politiques de santé
fondées sur ses connaissances l'un des
enjeux importants c'est de répondre aux
inégalités qu'elle soit sociale ou
territoriale elle pèse fortement sur la
santé
or selon l'adresse la France serait le
pays d'Europe où ces inégalités seraient
les plus fortes exemple l'espérance de
vie en bonne santé elle est de 69 ans
pour un cadre et de 59 pour un ouvrier
et ça commence dès l'école maternelle
13% des enfants d'ouvriers seraient en
surcharge pondérale contre 8% pour les
enfants de cadres comprendre ces
inégalités et comment les réduire et
donc indispensable pour créer des
politiques de prévention efficaces et
c'est tout l'enjeu de la recherche en
santé publique
alors dans les questions aussi de
définition qui fait de la santé publique
est-ce que comme son nom l'indique il
n'y a que le secteur public qui fait la
santé publique ou alors le secteur privé
s'empare aussi de ces enjeux alors c'est
une excellente question c'est vrai que
très souvent on pense que santé publique
= publique en fait sont tes publics veut
dire population et les acteurs privés
interviennent en matière de santé
publique bon certes il y a les
organismes publics de recherche mais il
y a également des fondations des
associations vous avez les industriels
typiquement l'industrie pharmaceutique
par exemple lorsqu'ils font des essais
thérapeutiques d'une certaine manière
utilise les les paradigmes de la santé
publique pour rebondir sur votre
question les médecins spécialistes de
santé publique n'ont pas le monopole de
la santé publique ce que c'est ce que je
vous évoquais un petit peu en substance
tout à l'heure il y a plein de
disciplines dans la santé publique de
l'économie de la sociologie des sciences
politiques de la géographie des
statistiques peu importe et bien c'est
autant de spécialistes qui peuvent d'une
certaine manière contribuer à la santé
publique c'est passionnant justement
l'excès les parents c'est interrogé ou
plutôt étalé à la rencontre de ses
chercheurs en santé publique qui
travaille sur enfin avec un outil on
connaisse-nous mais on voit pas toujours
ce que ça recouvre cet outil c'est la
cote l'accord c'est encore une fois un
levier très intéressant de santé
publique et notamment des plus anciennes
cohortes on va voir ce que c'est
intéressant
elle s'appelle E3N génération on regarde
leur portage et on se retrouve juste
après
[Musique]
c'était il y a un peu plus de 30 ans
je pense
en 1990 Michel est invité à participer à
une grande étude de santé publique
l'étude E3N
[Musique]
tout de suite je me suis dit ah ben au
moins c'est quelque chose de concret je
me suis dit que que de toute façon ça
pouvait être
utile c'était quand même des
renseignements fiables pour pour des
gens qui faisaient de la recherche
aujourd'hui à 75 ans Michel est toujours
très investi dans l'étude
tous les deux ans environ elle reçoit un
questionnaire à remplir
alors les boissons chaudes
volume du contenu représenté
alimentation mode de vie exercice
physique vie quotidienne et même
sentiment tout est passé au crible avec
une grande précision
si on veut vraiment être précis il y a
des mesures à prendre donc c'est vrai
que le questionnaire par moment c'est un
peu lourd
c'est peut-être un peu exagérer un peu
pénible mais d'un autre côté c'est vrai
que vous dites il doit pas y avoir le
temps de que ça qui
qui remplissent soigneusement ou qui le
renvoie ou qui peut encore le remplir
une tasse parfois rébarbative mais
pourtant essentielle
c'est ici que le questionnaire est
traité et réceptionné
comme Michel 100 000 femmes ont été
recrutés pour participer à l'étude de
trois n on appelle ça une corde
leur réponse sont stockées dans ce
sous-sol de l'Institut Gustave Roussy
ces archives sont une fierté pour John
Luca Sévery coordinateur de l'accord
plus d'un million de questionnaires
des informations énormes riches
grâce à l'engagement de ces femmes c'est
assez extraordinaire
si toutes ces réponses sont aussi
précieuses c'est qu'elles permettent aux
chercheurs d'en savoir plus sur
l'apparition de maladies
pour avoir une puissance statistique est
déterminée certains liens entre les
facteurs de risque et les maladies c'est
pour ça qu'on a besoin de
dizaines de milliers centaines de
milliers de personnes et de beaucoup de
données collectées dans le temps
au cours de ces 30 ans l'accord de
troisième a permis de mener des
centaines d'études
c'est en particulier dans la prévention
du cancer et notamment ses liens avec
l'alimentation que les recherches ont
permis de grandes avancées
et dans ce domaine les questionnaires ne
sont pas les seuls outils des chercheurs
ce bâtiment abrite l'autre grande
richesse de l'accord de trois n une
bille au banque
cette chercheuse travaille dans l'équipe
de John Luca Severin
les années 90
25000 échantillons de sang sont stockés
ici et toujours utilisé par les
chercheurs
Francesca Mancini a trouvé la présence
de certaines substances chimiques
toxiques qu'on retrouve dans
l'alimentation les pifaces selon cette
étude il pourrait y avoir un lien avec
le cancer du sein on a pu comparer les
niveaux d'exposition donc le niveau des
présences de cette substance dans les
sangles avant le développement du cancer
et évaluer donc les potentiel
associations de cette exposition avec
les risques de développer les cancer du
sang et les résultats ne se gèrent que
en fait il y a une association positive
entre l'exposition assez substances et
les risques développer les cancers du
sein mais surtout le risque de
développer des cancers du sang qui ont
peu définir
hormonaux sensibles
pour aller encore plus loin dans la
recherche l'accord s'est élargi il y a
quelques années en intégrant les enfants
des premières participantes leur
conjoint puis récemment leur petit
enfant
cet aspect familial ouvre de vastes
possibilités pour la science et pour
l'étude de Francesca Mancini
non notre avantage c'est qu'on a un
deuxième propolation la deuxième
génération qui sera déjà adulte au
moment où on rentre dans notre étude et
donc ça nous permettra d'étudier des
relations entre les comportements de la
mer et les risques de développer
certains pathologies à l'âge adulte de
des enfants
avec aujourd'hui 12700 familles suivies
sur deux générations la corde E3N
génération souhaite rassembler au total
200 000 participants
une nouvelle collecte d'échantillons
sanguins est prévue afin de poursuivre
l'étude
[Musique]
alors docteur vous la connaissez bien
cette corde elle est connue comme le
loup blanc ça fait 30 ans qu'il existe
comme c'est considérable c'est un
exploit en effet le sens même des Cortes
c'est leur longévité leur longévité plus
elle s'allume vous avez raison c'est les
deux c'est le temps et le volume plus on
a donné plus les données sur un temps
long et plus on peut creuser de
problématiques en matière de santé donc
c'est une corde assez exceptionnel
effectivement le fait de voir que des
personnes sont motivées à continuer à
répondre aux questions 30 ans après
c'est quelque chose d'exceptionnel c'est
fascinant c'est fascinant c'est facile à
trouver des volontaires pour des corps
dans cette très difficile c'est très
difficile et je dois avouer que
concernant cette corde il y a une
particularité sociologique si je puis
dire puisque cette corde a été
constituée à partir de femmes
enseignantes et on sait que les
enseignants d'une manière générale
effectivement sont beaucoup plus
sensibles aux problématiques de la
recherche par rapport au reste de la
population générale
est-ce que les grandes épidémies alors
je pense au VIH par exemple dans les
années 80 évidemment le covid plus près
de nous ce sont des accélérateurs en
termes de recherche de santé publique ah
oui c'est un accélérateur considérable
notamment effectivement l'épidémie du
VIH et j'irai un des leviers un des
facteurs explicatifs c'est dans quelle
mesure est-ce que les citoyens dans
quelle mesure est-ce que le débat public
se saisit de ces de ces problématiques
et c'est par le débat public par les
citoyens que finalement le renouveau de
la santé publique intervient et de la
même manière effectivement le VIH a été
un changement de paradigme je pense que
le covid sera aussi d'une certaine
manière un changement de paradigme en
tout cas on l'espère alors parfois les
recherches en santé publique elle est là
où on l'attend pas c'est en tout cas le
sujet du reportage de l'extérieur qui
est allé voir notamment comment des
chercheurs s'appuient sur des
interventions très concrètes
ça s'appelle la recherche
interventionnelle on va en parler dans
un instant en tout cas elle a suivi une
chercheuse qui étudie l'impact de la
végétalisation des cours d'école sur la
santé à Bordeaux reportage
[Musique]
quand on pense à la recherche
scientifique voici le genre d'image
qu'on a en tête mais en santé publique
ça peut parfois ressembler à ça étudier
le terrain
Linda Cambon et chercheuse son travail
comprendre comment l'environnement agit
sur la santé des enfants
la santé elle se construit là où on est
où l'on grandit où l'on vit où l'on
travaille et surtout elle se construit
dès le plus jeune âge c'est à dire que
ce que l'enfant va traverser
l'environnement va avoir un impact
majeur en fait sur son développement et
sur sa santé donc c'est un public qui
est vraiment privilégié en fait en
matière de santé publique c'est un
public qui est prioritaire concrètement
pour mener cette recherche elle s'appuie
sur une action entamée par la ville de
Bordeaux qui a décidé de végétaliser les
camps d'école et de les rendre plus
agréables ce jour-là les lieux à
l'origine du projet vient lui présenter
la cour de l'école Jacques Prévert
dans votre belle cour magnifique nous
sommes convaincus que ce projet permet
généralement un meilleur épanouissement
on va dire de l'enfant donc c'est
vraiment le respect de du rythme de
l'enfant on va dire où les plus calmes
et on va avoir un coin calme où ils
peuvent venir avec un bouquin d'autres
mains s'ils veulent faire des jeux avec
leurs amis ils pourront le faire ça
c'est ce qui a imaginé la mairie
à partir de là la chercheuse souhaite
étudier s'il y a bien un impact de cette
action sur la bonne santé des enfants et
dans quelles conditions cette démarche
est appelée recherche interventionnelle
une des spécificités de la recherche
interventionnelle c'est de produire des
conclusions circonstanciées là où les
recherches traditionnelles vont produire
des conclusions dans le langage
scientifique on dit toute chose étant
égale par ailleurs c'est-à-dire hors
contexte ce que l'on observe c'est que
ça peut pas se déployer après sur le
terrain parce que on n'a pas pris en
compte ce contexte et la manière dont il
va influencer et du coup la recherche
internationale elle prend en compte ce
contexte et elle va vraiment analyser
l'effet de ce contexte là et ça ça
nécessite de partir de vrais
expérimentations de terrain sauf que
justement sur le terrain Linda se rend
compte que la nouvelle cour de récré ne
fait pas forcément l'unanimité bonjour
les enfants
j'aurais envie de savoir ce que vous
pensez de cette cour d'école
il y a des points positifs et des points
négatifs c'est mieux parce qu'il y a
beaucoup plus de végétations mais non on
a beaucoup moins la place
il faut se laisser la possibilité de pas
entendre ce qu'on a forcément envie
d'entendre voilà on n'est pas dans une
stratégie confirmatoire d'hypothèse en
fait on essaie de comprendre vraiment et
donc il faut se laisser surprendre par
le terrain et essayer de creuser le fil
comment ils vivent cet espace là est-ce
que ça leur fait du bien est-ce qu'il
regrette la cour d'avant qu'est-ce qui
aurait à changer qu'est-ce qui aurait à
modifier et on voit qu'il ressort des
choses qui pourraient être vu autrement
parce que ça a été là aussi penser quand
même dans dans la concrétisation par un
adulte et eux bah ça peut les gêner cet
espace-là peut les gêner où ils auraient
envie de l'investir différemment il
aurait envie d'espacer tel ou tel espace
donc c'est ça que je vais essayer de
comprendre pour pouvoir faire des
recommandations aussi d'aménagement au
fait enlever les barrières avoir plus
d'espace pas de copeaux et plus de
d'espace comme ça pour pouvoir courir
c'est ça
avant d'avoir les premiers résultats
Linda et son équipe devront encore
interroger et observer régulièrement
tous les acteurs concernés par le projet
un travail assez long qui peut être un
frein au développement de ce type de
recherche
au CHU de Bordeaux le professeur
François alla dirige le service qui
porte cette étude
il déplore le manque d'ampleur de la
recherche interventionnelle en France
on travaille pas sur une politique comme
on travaille sur un médicament pour
faire le parallèle avec la recherche
clinique et donc effectivement c'est de
la recherche qui est complexe qui
nécessite du temps qui nécessite
beaucoup d'investissements humains de
beaucoup de disciplines et de
compétences différentes et c'est vrai
que c'est difficile de la mettre en
oeuvre particulièrement en France où
elle est peu soutenue
institutionnellement jusqu'à aujourd'hui
en France la recherche interventionnelle
représente moins de 1% des financements
accordés à la recherche publique en
santé
son développement pourrait pourtant
participer à établir de meilleures
politiques de prévention
[Musique]
alors docteur Lukasi la recherche
interventionnelle j'y reviens
ce qu'elle a de spécifique dans le fond
elle a une particularité c'est que elle
aide à faire face à une des grandes
limites notre système de santé qui est
les inégalités de santé on a de gros
inégalités de santé dans notre pays je
peux vous donner deux chiffres deux
exemples il y a une différence de 13 ans
d'espérance de vie chez les hommes entre
les 5% les plus riches de notre
population et les 5% les plus
défavorisés un autre exemple c'est que
la probabilité de mourir à AJ =
peut-être le double entre deux personnes
qui habitent à quelques kilomètres
seulement et bien la recherche
interventionnelle est un des outils qui
permet de lutter contre les inégalités
de santé par exemple ça c'est relatif
beaucoup aux conditions de travail ou
parler dans le débat public récemment
mais c'est pas le domaine de la santé
publique ça alors ce n'est pas le
domaine de la médecine mais c'est le
domaine de la santé publique le domaine
de la santé par définition il est pluris
sectoriel on parle de déterminant de
santé je vous passe le jargon mais ça
veut dire qu'est-ce qui influe sur la
santé et vous l'avez très bien dit
la génétique la naissance tellement de
facteurs énormément de facteurs tout est
dans la santé en réalité et la recherche
interventionnelle elle permet d'une
certaine manière d'aller s'attaquer aux
déterminant sociaux donc la composante
sociale de la santé alors on profite de
cette émission évidemment pour
interpeller un député sur une question
qui vous tient que en l'occurrence Cyril
Isaac Sibille du MoDem vous lui avez
demandé comment adopter une démarche de
santé dans les différentes politiques
publiques en écoute sa réponse
toute la problématique actuelle c'est
que
le système de santé est tourné vers le
système de soins alors que comme on le
disait effectivement le soin ne joue que
pour 20-25% de l'amélioration de notre
santé et que tout le but immense c'est
d'améliorer la prévention l'assurance
maladie c'est une promesse qu'on a fait
aux Français c'est dire que tu es si
vous êtes malade on prendra en charge
les soins maintenant ce qu'il faut c'est
faire une nouvelle promesse aux Français
si les directives on va s'occuper on va
vous favoriser les bons comportements en
santé et donc la promesse qu'on doit
faire actuellement séparer de la
prévention et des bons comportements et
du bon environnement pour la santé et
comme vous dit de manière globale qui
touche l'ensemble des politiques
[Musique]
vous me disiez tout à l'heure la santé
publique elle est partout on a parlé du
monde du travail la santé en fait elle
est partout la santé donc 500 de limiter
le champ de la santé publique au
ministère de la santé c'est une vraie
question c'est une vraie question de
fond que beaucoup de chercheurs se
posent certains recommandent finalement
que la santé soit intégrée dans une
forme de comité interministériel alors
il y a déjà ce genre de communauté qui
ont été mises en place mais vraiment de
pousser de pousser je dirais la logique
et de faire en sorte que finalement on
évalue l'impact de l'ensemble des
politiques publiques dans le dans le
monde de la santé avant de avant de les
lancer pour conclure docteur si je vous
demande comme ça un peu abruple
pourpoint une belle étude dont la
recherche en santé publique peut être
fière en France
qu'est-ce qui vous vient à l'esprit
alors il y a une étude dans le santé
publique qui va peut-être illustrer ce
que j'évoque depuis tout à l'heure qui a
étudié finalement les gains d'espérance
de vie les 30 ans de gains d'espérance
de vie au siècle dernier et cette étude
conclut que 25% des 30 ans d'espérance
de vie gagner sont liés au système de
santé en tant que tel ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que le reste l'immense
majorité près de 75% du reste des 30 ans
d'espérance de vie gagné et bien sont le
fait de choses qui sont en dehors du
système de santé nos comportements les
comportements l'amélioration des
conditions de vie des vous avez parlé
tout à l'heure des conditions de vie au
travail l'alimentation l'alimentation
l'activité physique la santé publique
elle mesure elle nous a indiqué des
choses très précises sur l'impact de
l'activité physique sur la santé
exactement tout ça pourquoi on le fait
pourquoi il y a des politiques ensuite
qui sont mises en oeuvre c'est parce que
la santé publique arrive à déterminer ce
type de déterminant exactement c'est la
santé publique qui a permis de montrer
que finalement défaut d'activité
physique et la sédentarité sont des
facteurs de risque de cancer de maladies
cardiovasculaires c'est la santé
publique qui va aussi déterminer quelles
sont les politiques les plus efficaces
pour faire en sorte que les personnes
suivent les recommandations en matière
de d'activité physique donc vous le
disiez tout à l'heure la santé publique
elle est partout c'est passionnant ce
que vous faites merci infiniment docteur
merci d'avoir été avec nous dans cet
état de santé merci de nous avoir suivis
et à très vite sur LCP
[Musique]
LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec mgeen mutuelle santé prévoyance
vous a présenté état de santé
[Musique]